[Música]
estoy buscando real academia define
épico como algo grandioso como algo
fuera de lo normal
y me puse a buscar el antónimo y te
encuentras con cotidiano tiene que ver
qué tiene que ver con algo diario
y me puse a buscar qué es diario
y tú sales que es del día
y no te cuadra y no hay ninguna relación
en realidad de entre como alguien que
podría ser cotidiano normal diario
normal común y corriente pretende hacer
algo épico o extraordinario
y yo lo que vengo a contarles a mi
historia soy de guayaquil ochentero este
es el working de los 80 y me crié en un
barrio marginal bastante pobre temas de
drogas alcohol pandillas limitaciones en
acceso en educación en salud en
seguridad y demás y siempre nos
buscábamos el día a día estaba en una
escuela
viendo cómo crecer pero siempre me
cuestioné si alguna vez iba a poder
pisar la universidad
cuando tenía 10 11 años tuve en un día
dos desmayos en la mañana y uno en la
tarde
y mi mamá se asustó y me llevó al médico
y el diagnóstico fue que tenía epilepsia
epilepsia es una enfermedad que no se
cura que tienes que aprender a vivir con
eso ya los 10 años te complica todo
porque cuando me lo explicaban los que
me decían es no importa en qué momento
ni en qué lugar te va a dar una
convulsión vas a perder el sentido te
vas a caer te vas a desmayar
y yo alcancé a preguntar entonces no
puedo hacer nada me dice no puedes hacer
todo debes tomar en cuenta que esto
puede pasar
y ya era chico ya era limitado con
epilepsia
era como una especie de combo completo
con
y yo decía esto no puede ser por aquí y
esa noche mi mamá me reúne con mi papá y
mis dos hermanos y nos dice el hijito
hemos trabajado toda la vida y
honestamente y fuerte pero no vamos a
alcanzar a dejarles un patrimonio
interesante vamos a apostarle a la
educación y no lo entendí fui a jugar
pelota en la tarde y no sé en donde
escucharon ellos que el tema de la
educación realmente puede ser el camino
a romper ese bendito círculo de la
pobreza y me meten en un colegio militar
no el mejor de guayaquil ni el más caro
pero era el el máximo que ellos creían
que podían pagar porque creían porque me
votaban todos los meses por falta de
pago y todos los meses me sacaban llega
a los 15 años ya te molestas ya te da
vergüenza hablar con el rector y le
dices que tengo que hacer para que no me
siga votando y me dice tienes que pagar
pues si estás en un colegio privado
tienes que pagar por un servicio si no
lo pagas no hay servicio fin de la clase
de economía
y yo dije pero entonces que hago la
única opción se llama beca y eran 15
años y era la primera vez que ya
escuchar a esa palabra beca bueno
entonces que si consigues la beca ya ya
no pagan nada no pagó nada no nada y que
tengo que hacer 97 sobre 100 92 sobre
100 nada más que eso no nada más que eso
y salí de la oficina
regresé a los tres meses con 97 sobre
100 y le dije el rector vengo a decir no
vengo a pedir la beca ven vengo a
decirle que está mal que le que le
mientras un joven me dice no está
equivocado
tienes la beca completa entonces
imagínate para mí 15 años chico que por
primera vez en su vida se convertía
inútil porque no estaba trabajando
seguía estudiando pero ya no era una
carga económica para a mi padre
me doy cuenta de esa puerta de ese hueco
de esa salvación con educación y le
cuento a mis hermanos un año y medio
después los tres estábamos becados y
seguíamos avanzando
cuarto año becado a quinto año pecado
sexto año pecado llega a la universidad
y dices ok mamá quiero ir al zamorano yo
creo que mi mamá es la mujer que más me
quiere en el mundo
y ella me dice bájate de esa nube
entonces yo no entendía por qué y me
dice mira estamos dando es cara y está
afuera tú eres chico y estás adentro no
empata y en algún momento te vas a pegar
una estampada allí y esto si digo pero
se acaba de conseguir tres años becas
puedo conseguir una beca en la
universidad si efectivamente si dios lo
permite ok y digo voy a empezar a
conseguir beca pero no me no puedo jugar
tanto y me meta en la politécnica a
estudiar ingeniería en estadística pero
siempre pensando en el zamorano primer
año la politécnica consigo el 25% de
beca no me servía segundo 50 tercer año
en la politécnica 75% de beca el 25
puede sonar poquito pero de chico
cuarto año empiezas a hacer ya las
materias enrumbadas a hacer todo el tema
de tesis y consigues la beca y yo recibo
esa llamada en el bus camino a la
politécnica y me dijeron tienes la beca
completa con un requisito ya empezamos
clases tienes que venir en una semana me
acuerdo que me bajé del bus en la espol
me crucé la calle y me regrese a la casa
nunca más fui a la politécnica
tampoco tuve que pensar mucho en
abandonar la politécnica porque al final
del día venía persiguiendo un sueño que
en algún momento se cumplió y dije wow y
me fui a zamorano y regresé y fui a mi
maestría y regresé
y me encuentro con la antártida
mentalmente
siempre me llamó la atención los polos
como será este sitio
ha brincado una en realidad debería
haber medido la patagonia
si pueden reír de zelda
y en quito y en quito conozco
las montañas nevados lagos lagunas y
demás yo ya corrí en guayaquil un
kilómetro a kilómetro y medio cuando me
cambio acá
la verdad que fue súper complicado el
tema de quito por la altura pero también
emocionante porque ya pasó de correr un
kilómetro cinco kilómetros como estaba
corriendo 5 dije me voy a escribir en
una carrera de 10 y esa carrera tenía
categorías 10 20 50 y 80 kilómetros y me
dice el señor 10 está lleno 20 está
lleno si quiere 50 y yo digo dame 50
pues entonces y me meto en una vuelta
endemoniada me demoro 15 horas llegó
penúltimo y eso porque le gané un
gordito al final pero llegó y ya cuando
estoy en la montaña digo bueno si ya
corre 50 pues que viene se inventen
después estaba en la patagonia argentina
corriendo 160 kilómetros
y mi cálculo fue haber millán si ya
corriste 50 160 es como hacer unas tres
vueltas más 10 de yapa y eso dije y dije
entonces si lo voy a hacer y me meto
aquí porque se ve lindo pero metete pues
a correr y yo termine después de 58
horas en este infierno aprendí todo en
el camino y también aprendí que las
personas crecemos cuando conectamos a
nuestros miedos uno viene a la tierra
por dos cosas o bien a vivir o bien a
crecer si quiere vivir y se queda en la
zona de confort y piensa que todo está
bajo control y no toma retos toma
actividades y no toma metas ley le llama
metas pero metas que sabe desde el día
uno que la va a cumplir básicamente por
un tema de ego estoy cumpliendo mi meta
sí sí sí sí pero hace tres años sabía
que le iba a hacer después a innovar la
cosa se crece en el miedo en la penumbra
en el desafío en la tiniebla en el
pánico en el terror en el que tú mismo
desconfía de tus propias capacidades
quieres emprender emprende puede
entonces pero cae te revuelca te
límpiate el polo y sigue avanzando por
allí va el reto
la patagonia me di cuenta que la única
forma de que podemos crecer en la vida
es en una modalidad de miedo y de pánico
no hay otra forma si ustedes piensan que
tienen su vida bajo control básicamente
la están desperdiciando porque si yo no
sé y ustedes tampoco seguramente cuando
se van a morir tienen mucho más sentido
empezar a tomar retos que empezar a
inundarnos en actividades en jugar a ser
importantes en jugar a ser gerentes en
jugar estado ocupados cuando el sueño
que siempre hemos querido hacer está
abandonado en nuestra cabeza porque
porque evitamos el miedo porque evitamos
el fracaso porque en algún momento nos
pensamos perfectos y claro por
definición si eres perfecto no vas a
fracasar nunca pues entonces no queremos
enfrentarnos a la realidad por eso
elegimos un modelo que yo le llamo el
mundo perfecto que es el del whatsapp
todo el mundo allí resuelve todo y todo
el mundo opina de todo y son expertos en
todo sabían hace un año quién va a ser
el campeón mundial saben porque la
economía está complicada saben que está
la universidad debe hacer esto o lo otro
o lo otro o lo otro y cuando todas las
preguntas
porque no vas a la vida real y si no lo
podéis esto por esto por esto por esto
por esto pero si no tuviera esto fijo
que lo hago para ambos es el mundo
perfecto y cuando yo regreso de la
patagonia digo voy por mi siguiente reto
y mi siguiente reto fue avancemos mejor
y mi siguiente reto fue meterme en el
desierto del sahara discovery chanel de
verdad la categoría de la carrera a pie
más difícil en el mundo 240 km yo era un
corredor amateur y dije lo que no me
queda claro cómo lo voy a hacer pero lo
voy a intentar y me metí y todo el mundo
me dijo que estaba loco le conté a todo
el mundo incluso a mi asegurador
pero todo el mundo me dijo no va por ahí
la cosa quién te crees tú que te has
creído tú tú eres un corredor amateur
cómo lo vas a hacer pero al final del
día entre las tanto y te martirizadas
tanto que en algún momento se cumple y
cuando regrese de sahara dije bueno pues
que venga lo que tenga que venir
antártida
100 km en el lugar más frío del planeta
y claro un es mono
no había pisado o nieve no había pisado
en invierno de verdad y mi concepto de
frío era el aire acondicionado
y ese man quería correr 100 kilómetros
en el sitio en donde está el 90% del
hielo del planeta aquí está el 70% del
agua dulce congelada
este es nuestro futuro lo que no ha
salvado nada más y allí y ese año
clasifican 11 personas una mujer de
singapur o 9 vikingos y yo
y a correr se ha dicho la foto que venga
llega a las 4 de la mañana se imaginarán
y el polo sur 66 meses días seis meses
noche
y sales no sé cómo pero terminas esta
carrera y lo que quiero compartir te es
tienes que creerte es el sueño porque si
no te lo crees tú no se lo cree nadie
incluir a tu vieja porque a mí ya me
pasó eso ni ni tu mamá te cree en los
sueños la gente te cree los sueños
cuando los cumples pero cuando los
cuentas no se los cree nadie
y en el antártida me di cuenta de eso y
también me di cuenta que no sirve de
nada que tú consigas estos retos para
uno mismo porque eso se llama ego y
soberbia y allí me di cuenta que lo
importante en la vida es si conseguirlos
pero que sirvan para aportar porque si
no aportamos es ego y soberbia y allí me
cuestiono y digo
qué es lo que deberías hacer y también
entiendo un concepto nuevo que es
incómoda te no busquemos como buscamos
la incomodidad porque allí nos ponemos
en versión de crecer si no tenemos un
problema estamos perdiendo el tiempo si
no estamos asustados estamos perdiendo
el tiempo y cuando yo entendí incómoda
te dije entonces ya pues sí ya corre y
en la salvaje y más caliente en el más
frío ahora me voy a meter el más
profundo de la tierra en sudáfrica y lo
voy a conectar con el más cercano al sol
es chimborazo ustedes recuerdan a los
mineros chilenos a los que quedaron
atrapados
si ellos quedaron a 700 metros de
profundidad yo para meterme al sitio más
profundo tuve que bajar
cinco veces más llegar a tres mil 563
metros en sudáfrica y allí abajo correr
21 kilómetros en un kilómetro 123 como
un ratoncito no contento con eso sal a
la superficie toman un vuelo directo
ecuador en donde está el punto más
cercano al sol
este es el planeta visualizando como un
balón aplasta lo de la cintura queda más
ancha como estamos en la cintura el
chimborazo se sale está dos kilómetros
más cerca del sol que el mismísimo
everest y esa belleza está en el ecuador
se lo consultamos al récord guinness y
le dijimos quien intentaba hacer esto se
demoran dos meses y nos dicen
efectivamente no hay un humano que lo he
intentado ok un equipo ecuatoriano lo va
a hacer y empieza toda esta aventura de
intentar conectar esto
de intentar conectar esto y dijimos
bueno al final una es pobre pero
antojado y dije y dije lo que si yo
cuento esta historia no me la creen
mejor hagamos película y creamos frank
cortos son del núcleo del sol la
aventura que relata esta aventura y como
un equipo de cuatro de anda consigue el
primer récord guinness deportivo para el
ecuador y es lo quisimos esto la
historia
gracias de un tipo normal que sueño con
lo extraordinario y tuvo que ponerle
todas las horas de entrenamiento que se
requería para hacer algo que sonaba
imposible y allí estamos en la antártida
y ese es el y allí estamos en el sitio
más profundo de la tierra y esto que ven
acá es el primer récord guinness del
ecuador conseguido por un normal no
puede ser normal
muchas gracias cuando salimos de ese
infierno de ese hueco viajamos a ecuador
a este nuestro chimborazo y empieza el
desafío de poder correr 21 kilómetros
más y pasó lo que no queríamos que pase
bronquitis cuando estábamos en el sitio
más profundo no hay circulación de aire
lo sabíamos pero no lo habíamos
dimensionado cuando no hay circulación
de aire se intoxican los bronquios y acá
faltaba oxígeno por la altura entonces
aparte que no podía hacer respirar
porque los broncos estaban más tapados
el poco aire que entraba tenía menos
oxígeno y eso te va complicando porque
el reto era conseguirlo en menos de 80
horas y empieza el sufrimiento
llegó al refugio que los roja hace la
evaluación y dice tienen que suspender
esto el tipo tiene bronquitis estábamos
a cuatro mil 800 metros faltaba llegar
hasta 6 mil 280 metros sobre el nivel
del trataban 2000 metros y pico más no
se podía porque a manera que va subiendo
te falta oxígeno y tu bronquitis se va
agravando
y la sugerencia fue cancelen esto el gob
el grupo de personas especiales estaba
allí
y alcanzaron a decir que solo nos
acompañaban por un tema de evacuación
porque su especialidad es la educación
el equipo tenía que resolver si
continuamos o no no fue una discusión en
la que participe yo participo en mi
equipo y resolvimos seguir avanzando
5.900 el que está en el suelo soy yo
sacas
última ingesta ya mi cuerpo no podía ni
siquiera asimilar el alimento lo
vomitaba
y eso pasó en cinco mil novecientos
cincuenta en realidad cuando pasó eso
empezamos a bajar en lugar de estar
subiendo imagínate eso desmotivación
esto deberías estar subiendo pues no
bajan pero sigamos bajando hasta ver a
qué altura podrías comer en 5.900 fue mi
última ingesta y ahí me metieron todo lo
que tenían que meterme porque es la
única forma en la que puede comer en 6
mil 50 metros decidido no continuar
porque ya había perdido sentido ya mi
cuerpo no daba ya estaba en el borde de
la limitación física psicológica y
fisiológica
y allí me doy cuenta allí realmente 9
cuenta que la vida está para vivirla y
tomar retos y también recordar a todas
las personas que te dicen no y que te
dicen loco
y que te critican todo sin hacer nada y
allí también recordé que la única forma
de que podemos sumarle a nuestra vida y
a los de otros es con la inspiración
pero con la inspiración y en el esfuerzo
porque el éxito no está en pasar la meta
final el éxito está en entregarlo todo y
yo sabía que ahí faltaba un poquitito
más de entregar hasta que lo conseguimos
llegamos
42 minutos después y gracias a dios ya
la vida llegamos a la cima del volcán
chimborazo conectando el punto más
profundo del planeta con el más cercano
al sol demostrando que si se puede y que
ser normal no significa que no podemos
hacer cosas extraordinarias
gracias
[Aplausos]
porque la vida puede ser tan cotidiana
como la querramos pero tenemos que
ponerle la parte épica de allí viene en
la parte de lo épico de la cotidianidad
no nos creíamos normales ni mediocres
lan avancemos y lancemos hasta el
siguiente nivel yo solo quiero dejarles
una reflexión pequeña que es todos aquí
tenemos límites y ante esos límites dos
opciones en la primera elegimos estar
lleno de actividades pensar nos que
somos la mamá de tarzán pero básicamente
sin hacer nada y pensar que nos vamos a
morir cuando nos da la regalada gana' y
en la segunda entendemos que los límites
están para romperlos y es que nuestra
obligación moral empujar a nuestra vida
un poquito más allá y tomar retos tomar
sueños y caernos las veces que tenemos
que caernos porque en los fracasos en
las caídas realmente está el verdadero
éxito porque sabemos que estamos en el
camino correcto en el camino hacia
conseguir lo que realmente queremos
porque pasamos a hacer
miserables de la vida viviendo lo que la
vida te ofrezca a realmente hacer dueños
de esta tomar los todos por los cuernos
y seguir avanzando porque vale mucho más
equivocarnos por precavidos por atraer y
dos que equivocarnos por precavidos por
pensar que no quiero fracasar sin el
fracaso realmente en el fracaso está en
el deck está el éxito al final del día
amigos cada uno deciden qué hacer con
sus límites muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]